like kids we're just about to take off
I'm a little nervous but I'm sure I'll
be back soon
first up the mighty blue fire roller
coaster
this ride goes from zero to 100
kilometres an hour in just 2.5 seconds
the highlight of course is the
loop-de-loop what an adrenaline rush
if absolutely I survived I'm a bit
shaken up but it was really fun
there are more than a hundred different
attractions including 13 roller coasters
and new features are being added all the
time
like the dome of dreams a 360 degree
multimedia cinema
[Music]
there is a good reason for calling this
place Europa Park Russia Greece Iceland
and many other European countries are
represented here each country has its
own special attractions in Spain for
instance visitors can enjoy a stunt show
[Music]
another highlight is the boat ride on
the Europa part lake a quiet moment to
ask other visitors what they like best
about the park it's walking in the park
it's seeing all these beautiful decorous
all the countries that are representing
I really like it here the blue fire is
sensational it's really fast best park I
knew
[Music]
my visit here is just about over I'm now
at this super splash Atlantica this
attraction is really popular in the
summer time because chances are you'll
get an impromptu shower which will help
you cool off
[Music]
okay as you can see I got really wet but
that's perfect in this weather
so I'm going to sit down in the Sun to
dry off goodbye from her over park
you